[MUSIC]
Don't be scared to be yourself,
that's the first thing I will tell
you before applying to Stanford.
Because people think
there's a perfect mold for
an MBA student that they have to follow,
and that's simply not true.
>> I interviewed with a CEO of
a local medical device company,
so I was applying out of undergrad.
So, to go walk into a room and sit
across the table from a CEO of a public
company was a little intimidating
as it would be for most people.
I think the thing that that stood
out to me from that experience was,
it was a fairly informal conversation.
Incredibly down to earth, and
really he was more interested in what I
wanted to do and what my passions were,
than sort of validating and checking
boxes on, do I fit particular criteria?
>> There's an overwhelming feeling
when you come to the GSB that you're
inadequate.
And you feel it when you're applying,
you feel it when you're talking to all
the other people that are applying.
But if there's one thing that I've
learned this year, is that I'm not.
And that maybe I didn't work for
Michelle Obama,
maybe I didn't cure polio,
but I'm special in my way.
And if you give yourself that faith
in yourself when you're applying and
push through the late nights, the edits
of your paper and the crying maybe,
when you start thinking about
the pressures of writing them.
I would say, just have faith in
yourself and know if you don't apply,
then there's definitely not
a chance that you'll get in.
[MUSIC]